nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman
the third coronavirus stimulus package
has now
passed the house and senate of the
united states
slightly different versions were passed
meaning it will go back to the house for
expected signature tomorrow
but most notably the third coronavirus
stimulus package
passed the u.s senate with zero
republican support not a single
republican senator
voted for getting money to more than 80
percent
of americans and getting them some
stimulus during this once every 100 year
pandemic situation that we currently are
facing
let's look at senator patrick leahy
announcing the passage of the bill in
the senate to democratic applause
and i would say republican silence it
actually looks like republican absence
altogether take a look at this
no senator bush has changed the vote if
not
the yeas are 50.
the days are 49 the bill as amended
is passed
[Applause]
now there are many many things to talk
about here
first of all because the senate passed a
different version than the house like i
said
the bill now goes back to the house and
the house is expected to pass this
tomorrow tuesday
then it will go to joe biden for
signature and then
soon we will see money start to go out
could be within a week could be 10 days
could be a little longer now the bill is
1.9 trillion dollars in total
it includes fourteen hundred dollar
stimulus checks
for those making up to seventy five
thousand dollars a year it phases out to
zero at
eighty thousand dollars a year three
hundred dollars per week in enhanced
unemployment benefits through summer a
child tax allowance of up to thirty six
hundred dollars for one year
that that's actually really big and
that's something that here is being done
on a temporary basis but there are many
democrats who would like to see
um the tax code benefit parents
through making such allowances permanent
and that's something that we can talk
about as well the bill includes 350
billion dollars for state coronavirus
aid
34 billion dollars to expand obamacare
subsidies
and 14 billion dollars for vaccine
distribution now if you have kids
this is a big win for you you would
still get the 1400
stimulus check for each child and for
yourself
plus the tax credit is going up to the 3
600
or 3000 if the child is 6 and older
and there's really a lot here for
families with kids
and yet the bill passed 50 to 49.
the reason it's 50 to 49 is one
republican senator was missing because
of a family emergency
had he been there it would have been a
50-50 tie and then kamala harris would
have had to come in
and vote to break that tie kamala harris
didn't need to come in to break the
tie all 50 democrats voted yes all 49
republicans who voted
voted no and this gets into
discussions about the political process
that went into
getting us to where we are today there
are people
rightly frustrated by the watering down
of this bill by democrats
but there are also people reacting to
this stimulus saga by saying democrats
and republicans are the same
and they're equally worthless when it
comes to getting people money that they
need
the first take seems correct to me the
second take
is invariably wrong unquestionably wrong
i share your frustration and believe
it's terrible that biden
said this would happen right away but it
actually will be close to april before
people see money
i understood two thousand dollars to
mean two thousand more dollars
not 1400 more which makes it 2000 total
if you include
the 600 that will have been six months
before by the time people actually start
getting the 1400. yeah i i'm with you
right there
i hate that the 15 minimum wage was
removed from the bill
i hate that the bill further restricted
thanks to senate democrats
who qualifies at all for the stimulus
reducing it from a hundred thousand a
year to eighty thousand a year
this shows us some terrible realities
about the democratic party
including that the most centrist of the
senate democrats people like joe manchin
and jeanne shaheen
they are very soft democrats they're
obviously not progressives
and while they are democrats that
they're not republicans they are
democrats
they're very different than what you and
i might say
is the type of democrat that we want to
see in the u.s senate but
it's important to remember for those
like there's people mad at the
parliamentarian because the
parliamentarians said
you can't include the 15 minimum wage in
the bill but kamala harris could have
done an override
remember that even if kamala harris
overrules
the senate parliamentarian and says we
are putting the 15
minimum wage in the bill then you look
at the mansion vote
and likely some others and you don't
even pass the bill at all and no one
gets money
so there is a huge critique of the
democratic party to be made here
and it should be made and we've been
making it which is that lots of these
democrats
aren't very progressive at all at the
same time
the overruling on 15 minimum wage just
means it doesn't pass at all and i don't
think that's good either
now on the other hand every republican
senator voted for people to get
zero and look at what still democrats
were able to get done so this is the
other perspective
republican senator ron johnson for ro no
reason other than to try to delay the
bill although it failed
asked that the entire bill be read aloud
republicans have acted to get people
zero and to make it take as long as
possible
to give them zero and despite that
democrats have been able to pass and
when the house votes for the updated
version of the bill they will pass
a nearly two trillion dollar bill that
puts
thousands of dollars into the bank
accounts of the typical family of four
between the stimulus money
and the child credit it establishes the
country's first
real child allowance it's only on a
temporary basis for now
but there's the possibility it could be
made permanent which it should be
this is obviously nowhere close to what
the american people deserve
but it's important to resist the urge to
self-righteously
slam it all write it off and say
democrats and republicans are the same
this is a major legislative
accomplishment and it's desperately
needed by joe biden
it's not what was promised and it took
way too long and those are critiques
that are fair
so when we equate republicans and
democrats here it's silly
although there are many criticisms to be
made of democrats their positions aren't
even remotely comparable though
morally and legislatively to those of
republicans now if you were going to
claim
that this is merely happening democrats
vote yes republicans vote no
because joe biden is president and if
things were reversed then it was a
republican president you would have the
reverse situation
the answer is obviously not democrats
voted for
every coronavirus relief bill during the
trump administration
not a single republican voted for joe
biden's coveted relief bill and that
yet you still have republicans lecturing
democrats about the need for unity and
bipartisanship and we're
supposed to pretend both parties are the
same so give me a
come on guys you've got to give me a
break on that this
is the most loser of loser politics
but republicans and democrats are
nowhere near the same on this let's get
this signed let's get money to the
people
let's move on to the 15 minimum wage and
health care and vaccine distribution
and uh starting to open things up as
cases and deaths
come down significantly more hopefully
over the next two to three months
and all of the other things that need
our attention
over this weekend we surpassed a major
coveted vaccination milestone and we
came
very close to surpassing another on
saturday the u.s
injected 2.9 million
vaccines into people's arms almost
half a million more than the previous
single day record of about 2.4 million
vaccines in a day
and we are just shy of 3 million
vaccines a day
that is a real possibility in the three
days this past weekend friday saturday
sunday
more than 7.7 million vaccines were
injected in just
three days these are the types of
numbers that will turn the pandemic
around if they can be sustained
look at how quickly this has ramped up
when donald trump left office
the seven day average of vaccinations
was
890 000 a day thanks to joe biden
working with pfizer and moderna to ramp
up supply to states and getting the
vaccine to states importantly
because we had this situation under
trump where as pfizer and modern were
reporting deliveries
and yet hospitals and clinics were
saying we we don't have the vaccines
so that has been improved we now have
the addition of a third vaccine we may
have a fourth vaccine
we are now averaging 2.16 million doses
per day over the last week
we have a new high water mark of 2.9
million vaccines in a single day
right now by percentage the leading
states on vaccination are new mexico
alaska connecticut the dakotas
rhode island and massachusetts states
doing the worst on vaccination
percentage-wise are
georgia washington dc which isn't a
state
um alabama texas utah and tennessee
i believe that in the next week possibly
saturday that seems to be the big
vaccination day every week
we will get to 3 million vaccines in a
single day
and if you can make that steady you are
dramatically improving the timeline on
herd immunity compared to just doing a
million vaccines a day you're
you are moving it up uh in fact by
two-thirds
um the math of this is that if we can
accelerate to about three million doses
per day
we are looking at maybe three months
until we start getting into
the range of what we would consider to
be herd immunity um
could be could be three could be four it
could be two and a half you know if we
get to four million doses a day we could
really
get even closer it's not worth
calculating it with too much precision
there's no sense in saying
may 10th will be the day does it you
know that things change and shift
but when you think about three and a
half million a day
that's 210 million doses in 60 days
if you assume 80 of those are the two
shot regimen
and the rest or the one shot you're
maybe looking at fully vaccinating 125
million people in the next two months
30 million are already vaccinated and
then that means that like maybe
one more month you know 90 days from now
we are starting to get into the range
of herd immunity now there's tons of
work to be done we're racing
against variance against which the
vaccines are not quite as effective in
terms of preventing illness preventing
disease altogether but very effective at
preventing serious disease disease and
hospitalization and death
so there's there's still a lot going on
here and in the next couple of days
the cdc will put out new guidelines for
vaccinated people
i expect that reading that will
encourage more people to want the
vaccine it's
anticipated the cdc will say it's fine
for vaccinated people
to gather indoors in small groups with
no masks
uh i i my thought is that as people
start to see these vaccines actually do
have an impact on
not only the nationwide numbers but what
you can do
that more and more people are going to
want the vaccine and as soon as the cdc
puts out those guidelines we will have
them for you
a very exciting on march 26th
we are going to be doing our next single
day membership special we haven't done
one of these for months
i wish i could tell you there was some
really exciting reason why we're doing
it
the reason we're doing it is february
was the worst month in more than a year
from the standpoint of memberships
the economic situation has led to a lot
of people having to cancel memberships
february being only 28 days
left literally fewer days for people to
sign up february was
a disastrous month for us as far as
memberships go so we are going to have
a one day huge membership blowout
friday march 26th if you want to be
notified about this membership special
just get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com real easy
and then a friday morning march 26th you
will get a perfect email
with a spectacular coupon code telling
you exactly how to
sign up at what is close to an illegal
discount it's certainly an immoral
discount
it may even be illegal in some states
but don't worry
nobody's going after anybody for this
stuff so get on the newsletter mailing
list at davidpakman.com
let me know your thoughts on vaccination
and how it's going you can find me
on twitter deepakman the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money
helping the environment but it's
actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
off all nebia products
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the david pakman show does
depend on the support of viewers and
listeners who grab
memberships at joinpackman.com
grab one today let's talk about jobs we
are
starting to see better and better jobs
numbers
as coronavirus cases have been declining
hospitalizations have been declining
deaths while still tragically high
are also declining and hopefully this is
going to continue
in february non-farm payrolls went
up 379 000 even though the expectation
was only 210
000. so the real numbers exceeding the
expectations
by about fifty percent in more in fact
the unemployment rate was expected to be
six point three percent it came in
lower at six point two percent
and this is of course just the start
there is a huge way to go
to recover from this pandemic the
pandemic is nowhere near over
2 000 people a day are still dying
every day in the united states although
we're starting to to point
to below those numbers but this is still
something now
let's do the normal disclaimers on the
show if you're a new viewer
or a new listener i don't play these
republican democrat games
with jobs numbers and with the
unemployment rate that i know that on a
lot of shows they do this with gas
prices
they do this with debt and deficit they
do this with unemployment numbers and
jobs numbers this is not the show if
you're looking for that garbage
first of all this has very little to do
with joe biden
so far joe biden is rolling out vaccines
much faster than donald trump was that's
good and that is
starting to help cases go down that is
the effect of helping businesses to open
but that moves really really slowly that
this is not really about joe biden
right now this is a result of broader
economic circumstances
the pandemic and it has little to do
with biden
nor trump although for sure had we had a
real adult response to the pandemic from
the federal government starting a year
ago
when it was trump we never would have
lost as many jobs as we lost and of
course we never would have lost as many
people
as we tragically lost but we've talked
about this many times before
uh and when we talk about jobs numbers
and administrations
second lots of people play this game
of oh david you're talking about the u3
when it's convenient
but you should really be talking about
the u6
i hate to even have to do this again but
as a reminder
there are many unemployment rates when
you hear on the news
the unemployment rate they are almost
always talking about what's called the
u3
there is another unemployment rate
called the u6 the u6
includes the people that we talk about
when we say
6.2 percent are unemployed but you add
to that discouraged workers in other
words those who
have not found a job want one but are
discouraged they're not even looking
anymore
and you add in people who are working
part-time but would rather be working
full-time they're only part-time because
they can't find a full-time job and
people love to play games
when the u3 goes down but you want to
criticize the president you say well
let's look at the u6
which is always higher right now over
the last month the u6 is unchanged it's
at 11.1
there's no reason to hide that again
this is not really a story about joe
biden anyway
this is a story about the reality of the
pandemic i know lots of shows
love to mess with this stuff we don't do
that the hospitality industry
is still three and a half million jobs
short
of where it was a year ago before the
pandemic exploded and if you look at
total employment
we have a long way to go there were more
than 152 million jobs before the
pandemic
there are now 143 million we are nine
million
jobs short of the pre-pandemic numbers
uh despite having more people living in
the united states than we did a year ago
now another attack on these numbers
that's meant to hurt joe biden
is people saying well but david a lot of
these new jobs
are part-time jobs that's true
and there are some unique circumstances
right now that explain that
lots of businesses are slowly reopening
businesses that have been closed or
places that have been reduced for
example
to a restaurant that's take out only um
that is going to start going in the
direction of opening back up a lot of
these businesses are bringing people
back in for just a few days per week
and hopefully if all goes well if we
continue to do the things we have to do
many of those part-time jobs will turn
to full-time jobs as things continue
to recover that this is 90 about the
reality of the situation not about trump
or biden
per se with the very important caveat
that if trump had
managed this well it never would have
gotten as bad as it got
so the takeaway is slow improvements
the better vaccination rollout goes and
the more people resist the urge
to just open everything wide open and go
crazy
the more quickly these numbers are going
to be able to recover
if things go perfectly i mean listen
there's different estimates if things go
perfectly
you could see the bulk of the recovery
happen during this calendar year
some industries are even if everything
goes as well as possible
will not be fully recovered this year
regardless and
travel some estimates say travel won't
fully recover
until summer of 2022 or even later
i think you know things change so
quickly that any predictions going so
far out are of limited value but the
point is we still have
a long road ahead of us and it's made
longer
by people like the ones i'm going to
talk about next if you want to see
a prototypical example of bottom of the
barrel
counterproductive dangerous backwards
ignorance and weaponized thinking look
no further
than at what happened in idaho over the
weekend
on the steps of the idaho state capitol
in boise idaho
parents and their children
staged an anti-mask protest
where they had a fire going in a barrel
and they
angrily threw surgical and other types
of masks
into the barrel in what i guess was
supposed to be some kind of defiant and
principled statement about
not being forced to wear masks
or not believing in the pandemic or
about being angry that there are covet
guidelines
and this is obviously bad enough at the
surface level the idea that wearing
masks to be part of keeping people safe
and reducing the spread would make
anybody angry
that's that's bad that's a problem but
also on a very practical level
many masks include plastic fibers and
other things that
you don't want to be burning and
breathing in and yet parents
and their children encouraged by their
parents are participating gleefully
and breathing in the smoke from the
masks it's all insane
protesting guidelines meant to stop the
spread of a respiratory virus
by breathing in harmful fumes from
burning masks you can't write this stuff
you really can't
and adding to the absurdity is that
idaho doesn't even have a state mass
mandate
you you're they don't have one you would
typically protest at the state capitol
when
the governor or the state legislature is
doing something you don't like
idaho has no mass mandate why are they
protesting at all
never mind at the capitol well visitors
to the capitol buildings specifically
are asked to wear masks
it's not even required or enforced
republicans introduced a bill last week
to ban mass mandates in idaho
republican governor of idaho brad little
has never issued a statewide mass
mandate
there are some individual counties there
are some cities
that have mass mandates maybe they
should be protesting there
instead of at the state capitol but
really they shouldn't be protesting at
all
i may be trying to apply logic to a
situation where clearly there is no
logic and the involvement of children in
this
makes it extra disgusting like what are
you teaching them here
while you have them breathe in the fumes
of burning masks
you teach them to disrespect government
buildings by making a fire on the front
steps of one
playing with fire irresponsible mask
behavior because
of course while burning the masks
they're not wearing masks i mean kids
and adults
grabbing fistfuls of masks during a
pandemic and burning them
you're really not these aren't children
that you're you're setting up for upper
management let's put it that way
now how would this be different if
instead of going to a mask burning
they went to one of the refrigerated
morgue trucks that some hospitals
have parked outside because they don't
have enough room inside the hospital for
the dead bodies of people that died of
covet
or you go to some places where they're
holding memorials for the people that
died official officially 525 000
americans dead
if you estimate the uncounted deaths
could be more like 680 or 700 000 coved
deaths
but in idaho they're not going to look
at the morgue
trucks they're not going to do a
memorial for the people that died
they're holding a mask burning and this
is an example
of the type of stuff i've talked to you
about
that takes likely generations to fix
there's no simple fix to this
there's no specific intervention you can
do
that at a mass level will fix this type
of thinking and this type of programming
it's being bred into the children at a
young age
and it likely will take a generation to
make a dent
and that's if we do everything perfectly
that's if we reform education
that's if we uh get people media
literate enough
not to fall for the stuff that's on
right-wing media that it's
it's an uphill battle and that's tragic
and that's scary
let me know your thoughts we'll have
more coverage of this delusional mask
burning on the david pakman show
instagram page
you can find us there at david pakman
show and you can find me on instagram at
david.pacman as well
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
there's lots of uh debate
and there has been over time about if
and when and whether
it's ever okay to make an analogy to
hitler and to nazis and the analogies
often are not warranted they don't make
sense they're not well calibrated to
what we're looking at in the modern day
however on fox news a few days ago judge
jeanine pirro
went on a rant about hispanic immigrants
that is almost identical to the language
that we saw from nazis
and other anti-semites about jews in the
past
listen to what judge janine pirro had
you listen to me they've got coven
they've got
all kinds of diseases they are being
released into the united states
now you're not going to tell me the
governor is going to shut me down and
not allow me to do my job
and let any illegals because we've got a
heart
they have all sorts of diseases and
they're being released the way you would
release an
animal into the wild they're being
released into the united states
this is typical third reich anti-semitic
rhetoric used to justify the
genocide of jews during world war ii
replacing
jews with hispanic immigrants in the
story
it's the same language i'm not saying
judge jeanine
is hitler i'm saying this language is
the same
now you can even actually go back beyond
world war ii for this
if you go back to the black plague in
england
it was blamed on jews by anti-semites
the blaming
jews for disease is a really old thing
but if you look at third reich
propaganda specifically the
justification for the cleansing of the
population
was based on the idea of an alien race
of jews poisoning the culture bringing
disease
this exact type of thing we're seeing
from judge jeanine now again
as i mentioned last week even this type
of rhetoric
when you talk about coronavirus is
nonsense because the us
has a significantly higher per capita
case rate than mexico
there's no reason to think that covid is
coming from mexico
to the united states we have way more of
it here
but ignore that for now this type of
defiant
sounding anger from judge jeanine
was the same type of thing applied to
jews during hitler's germany
the dehumanization is present in so many
genocides
you look at the rwandan genocide as
another example
i recently read a very good book about
the rwandan genocide by philip gorovich
excellent disturbing but excellent book
the kernel of an idea that started the
genocide
and there's a lot of colonial uh forces
that
that sort of were involved in the
creation of this idea the idea was
that the hutus and the tutsis were
not only clearly distinct ethnic groups
but
one was sub-human one was dirty one was
unrefined and unsophisticated and the
hutus decided that the tutsis were
inferior
and they were off to the races with the
disgusting genocide
as i mentioned in our segment about the
fox news
focus on the border last week and will
again
this week during gensake's pres saki's
press briefings
this is what they've found as their new
punching bag
trump leaves and biden comes in the
country
has given joe biden the highest initial
approval for a president in nearly 30
years
seventy percent want coveted relief 80
percent agree with joe biden's federal
mass mandate for transportation and
federal offices
vaccination has tripled since joe biden
took over
the world is moving on from trump so
they have cultural issues
like dr seuss and supposed cancel
culture
and now they've fixated on the border
which shouldn't surprise us because this
has been their playbook for a long time
remember talking about a migrant caravan
leading up to the 2018 midterms
the day after the 2018 election we don't
hear about a migrant caravan
until october of 2020 when they need
that again
and part of this is also strategic
texas and mississippi are opening wide
open
even though health officials say it's
too early to do that they're getting rid
of mass mandates they're getting rid of
everything
ending that right now is likely to cause
a search
and they are preemptively on the attack
against hispanic immigrants to be able
to blame
them when the surge hits in places like
texas
judge jeanine obviously should be fired
for this
but is fox news going to fire her when
the audience loves this stuff
probably not so i would expect judge
jeanine
maybe she'll get a promotion and a raise
for this rant which even
if you watch the video she was alongside
geraldo there
even geraldo looked perplexed and sort
of distraught to the extent that he's
able to
uh during that absolutely outrageous
ramp
we haven't talked about any press
briefings by joe biden's white house
press secretary jen
saki for a bit we've been tied up with
other things like
coveted stimulus and much more but i
want to look at one today
because it's quite interesting what's
going on first of all
this first clip is cbs reporter ouija
zhang asking jen saki to respond to
claims that joe biden has opened the
border wide open and people are just
pouring pouring in
and it wasn't happening under donald
trump but it is now now it's really
important to remember
that even though donald trump didn't
build the wall during his presidency
he would regularly claim that he built
it
and that the imaginary wall was
responsible for record low undocumented
crossings now bear with me because this
requires
assuming multiple lies are true to
understand their
position if you believe trump that he
built the wall
and of course if you believe that joe
biden hasn't taken down that wall
you would have to imagine that the job
that the wall was doing at keeping
people out
when trump was president is still
keeping people out today
but the narrative has shifted into biden
has
opened the border and people with
diseases
are pouring in the nazi rhetoric that we
talked about earlier
and here gen saki smartly goes after the
idea of americans are saying
and gets reporter ouija zhang to admit
well i mean trump trump is the one
saying it and gensake quickly dispenses
with the nonsense
but a lot of americans are saying that
you know the surges are happening under
president biden's watch
after he reversed some previous policies
so
does the administration take any
accountability for
what's happening who are the americans
well
i know you don't want to answer to him
but the former president just
um released a statement saying that the
biden administration was act immediately
to end the border nightmare that they
have unleashed
on tarnishing former president trump yes
we don't take our advice or counsel
from former president trump on
immigration policy which was
not only uh inhumane but ineffective
over the last four years we're going to
chart our own path forward and that
includes treating children with humanity
and respect and ensuring they're safe
when they cross our borders
this is just so funny and i'm not even
really looking to criticize
wija zhang i think that she's asking
what are meant to be tough questions she
asks them of kaylee mcinanni
she asks them of gen saki it's more a
lesson in how vapid and politically
biased these claims
are where from trump's last day
to biden's tenth day republicans started
wildly claiming joe biden has opened the
border wide open
joe biden has dramatically changed
what's going on at the border when in
fact
if there's a real critique of joe biden
here it's that he hasn't changed that
much about what's going on at the border
since taking over despite promises to do
so we talked about that early last week
i won't
rehash the entire conversation just a
few
more funny examples of hijinks at the
latest press briefing
here's a reporter asking why joe biden
hasn't done a solo press briefing yet so
we're 45 days into the bibing presidency
and he has yet to hold oppressor
at this point in past presidencies every
president
you know from reagan had addressed
reporters some of them multiple times
so why the delay and when can we expect
the presidential hold of press
conference
well first as all of you know the
president takes questions several times
a week
he took questions actually twice
yesterday uh which is an opportunity for
the people covering the white house to
ask him about whatever news is happening
on any given day we look forward to
holding a full
press conference in the coming weeks
before the end of the month
and we're working on setting a final
date for that and as soon as we do we
will let you all know
i can really kind of see both sides on
this i mean
certainly presidents should be taking
questions from the press
it is true that while you usually see
both the president and their press
secretary taking questions in the press
briefing room
biden has hasn't done that yet but biden
is holding
covid related and other events almost
daily and he doesn't take questions
at all of them but he's taken questions
a whole bunch of times in his first six
weeks in office
sometimes as jensaki points out more
than once in a day okay
i mean the point is that the press in
the midst of what is at least for now a
very popular presidency all things
considered
biden again highest initial approval of
any president in 30 years almost 70
percent cove
relief support etc the press are having
to sort of manufacture
problems or scandals and it's not going
super well i think that there are
plenty of fair critiques they could go
after but they're going after other
things
one other example fox news reporter
stepping away briefly
from the dr seuss scandal which has been
24 7 on fox news for about a week now
to push this crisis at the border thing
and i think what jen saki
does well here she doesn't do everything
well but this she did well
she refuses to escalate into the
hysterical language that the reporter
from fox is baiting her with take a look
are there any discussions within the
white house about
reversing the policy of allowing all
unaccompanied children
in the united states no not at all
so i i guess is the plan then to
take in and safely and humanely find a
home
for an unlimited number of unaccompanied
children
i think this issue requires us taking a
step back as human beings
and as mothers of which i am one i know
there are many
in the room or many at home these kids
are coming they are fleeing prosecution
they are fleeing difficult circumstances
in their home country
when they come here all we're talking
about here is ensuring that they are
treated
safely they are not trafficked they are
not sent back
on a unsafe journey that's what we're
talking about when they come when these
kids come in it doesn't mean they are
insured that they get to stay
they go through the processing system
that everyone goes through but we want
to ensure that that is done
by treating them humanely and and with
respect many of them will be sent back
home eventually but we're talking about
uh how we treat them as they come in the
country now i have been critical of joe
biden
on immigration i think his one executive
order on stopping removals which was
stopped by a judge
wasn't enough he should have done
another one using a different different
legal rationale i talked about that last
monday but the hysterical critique that
policy has dramatically changed in six
weeks
resulting in people just now pouring in
uncontrollably
it's silly the projection that the fox
news reporter cites about 110 000 or
whatever that number was
we had similar projections under trump
the point is under trump
what they're counting on is that under
trump nobody who watches fox knew
that these are just the normal numbers
that immigration authorities are dealing
with
so when the fox news reporter there says
the expectation is 110 000
kids will come it sounds shocking but
there's nothing particularly notable
about those numbers
this is a huge country and those are the
same numbers we were seeing under donald
trump so
we'll see if and how
the tone and tenor of the briefings
change over time
for now this is what it's been like and
jen saki handling it
relatively well the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
let's take a quick tour through
appearances on right-wing media and by
republican politicians over the last 24
hours or so the big news of course we
covered it at the top of the show
that with absolutely zero republican
support in the senate
democrats passed a 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus bill which while not as big as
we want
not as soon as we want it doesn't
include the minimum wage it will put
thousands of dollars in the pockets of
families with children
it will provide a ton of money to
accelerate vaccination
and it was all done without a single
republican supporting it a great
question for these republican elected
officials would be
you know a lot of your constituents want
this bill and yet you voted against it
that was not the story on right-wing
media for the 24 for the last 24 hours
what is the right been up to
over this period of time let's take a
look
first example here is mississippi
governor tate reeves
who recently canceled all coveted
guidelines wide open state no more
masking nothing
tate reeves went on cnn and still
in nearly the middle of march would not
acknowledge that
joe biden simply won the election
take a look at this do you accept that
joe biden
is the legitimate lawfully accepted
lawfully elected president of the united
states
president biden is the president of the
united states
was he legitimate mail in voting
in our state we do not allow mail in
voting and the reason we don't allow
mail in voting is because we don't think
um that it we think that it allows for
lots of opportunities for fraud and
other things
and i don't think melon voting should be
allowed in other states around the
nation but
president biden is the duly elected
president and we're going to do
everything we can to work with him
to help the citizens of mississippi
there are lots of states
that trump won where there's mail-in
voting including florida
including ohio including utah i hear you
saying joe biden is the president i do
not hear you saying
he was legitimately elected fbi director
chris wray
former attorney general bill barr have
both stated there was no
widespread voter fraud none that could
have affected the outcome of the
november election
republican after republican ducey in
arizona
kemp in georgia your colleagues judge
after judge have rejected this rejected
this argument
this is a dangerous conspiracy theory
that tens of millions of people believe
it inspired a domestic
terrorist attack on the capitol yes or
no do you accept that the 2020
presidential election
was free and fair obviously every
election has some questions but i'm
talking about
free and fair legitimately elected joe
biden yes or no
as you said jake every election has some
questions and this one was no different
president biden is the duly elected
president of the united states that he
was
certified by all 50 states either having
won or lost he lost
my state by 20 points but he was
certified in each of the individual
states he was certified by the u.s
congress and he's the newly elected
president all right but that doesn't
mean that we don't have bad laws in the
books
in other states it's just a fact this is
their new refrain
when asked they say joe biden
is the president that is very different
than joe biden
actually won they are still going with
this they can't simply say
uh despite always having some anecdotal
individual allegations of irregularities
in every election
the number of alleged irregularities
wouldn't come every anywhere close even
if they were all proven to be true
to affecting who won and yes of course
joe biden won he says that well
oh you know i mean listen joe biden is
president but there were irregularities
and blah blah
blah it's four months guys it's four
months and if they're still saying it
now
they aren't going to stop anytime soon i
expect them to continue with this
all the way through to the 2024
presidential election
and in fact they'll use it to try to
justify continuing to suppress the vote
as we already see them doing more than
250 republican bills
in more than 40 states making it harder
to
vote so let's continue our tour
of what has been happening with
republicans and right-wing media
over the last day or two while democrats
were passing covet relief
over on maria bartiromo's fox news show
she invited on senator lindsey graham
to talk about of course trans women in
sports
hey listen at least it's not dr seuss
here's lindsey graham away with a
distinction between being a man and
woman
in the law biological boys are going to
start playing in girls sports
and if your religious organization out
there and your faith dictates that
certain things happen
this bill takes that ability now i've
talked about how trans women in sports
is a calculated
fabricated issue that does exist
but affects almost no one statistically
but also this idea from lindsay about
the laws are going to make our religious
beliefs irrelevant
they are the opposite of our religious
beliefs
who cares that's america we have
separation of church and state
you can privately believe whatever you
want
but you don't get to point to your holy
book and say
this belief of mine from my chosen
religion
dictates what the law should be if you
believe in zeus if you're a
a hellenist and you showed up and you
said
we must be allowed to do animal
sacrifices that's in our beliefs if you
don't allow that you're limiting our
ability to practice religion
civil law and government don't have to
allow that sorry guys you might believe
that but we have secular government no
can do
secular government shouldn't care what
your supposed holy book
says then one more from maria bartoromo
she casually mentions that we know covid
came from a chinese lab
and of course we we don't know that take
a listen
i haven't also heard president biden say
anything about
where the coronavirus originated we know
it originated in a wuhan lab
imagine that she's criticizing biden
for not having said where the virus came
from
first why does biden have to weigh in on
that he's the president he's not a
scientist the virus has been around now
since you know november december of 2019
in some way shape or form
why does joe biden need to weigh in on
that on that and secondly of course
we don't know that it originated in a
chinese lab that's maria
repeating it as fact when it is not fact
and then lastly
again as democrats were passing coveted
relief
here is radical republican trumpian
congresswoman lauren bobert on fox news
trying to make the case that i guess
what she's saying
is that undocumented immigrants are
drunk driving
and then not being punished or something
like that
schools they want to jail you for not
wearing a mask but want to keep illegal
aliens who are
i don't know drunk driving here in our
country
lauren bobert who we'll talk about more
in a moment clearly not understanding
how immigration law works in many states
and jurisdictions if you are drunk
driving and you are arrested
local police don't conduct immigration
investigations
local police if you're drunk driving
deal with the drunk driving whether you
are here illegally or not they don't
involve themselves in that
the the the idea of they want to keep
them in the country
couldn't be more deceptive and dishonest
so that's right-wing media during the
weekend a weekend in which
we scaled up vaccination and did nearly
eight million doses in three days past
1.9 trillion
in covet stimulus in the senate which
now goes back to the house
this is what they focused on what value
do they provide
what are they bringing to the table it
seems as though it's nothing but it's
actually something very important
they are providing a parallel agenda
setting
that is useful to those who want to
continue living in this alternate
reality and they are you know
biden most popular initial approval of
any president in 30 years people want
coveted relief and it passed
people increasingly want the vaccines
and they're scaling them up you need a
parallel
story to tell and increasingly it's a
story about
trans women in sports cancer culture
and undocumented immigrants that's the
story they've done and now let's talk a
little bit more about
lauren bober we've talked before
about the amount of projection in
american politics
and particularly among the american
right wing if they are accusing someone
of something they are almost certainly
doing it themselves
in a fox news segment that is beyond
satire
trumpian republican congresswoman lauren
bober
says democrats are obsessed
with conspiracy theories check this out
here she is on
judge jeanine pirro's show saying that
no one on the outside can get into the
capital
only because of these conspiracy
theories that democrats are obsessed
with which has led to
national guard troops you know i
remember something happening on january
6 that explains why the national guard
troops are there i think there's real
questions about how long are they
staying
but i seem to remember something
happening there on january 6th
anyway here's lauren bober no one on the
outside can get into the capitol it is
only staffers and and members of
congress
who are allowed at the people
house at our nation's capital judge
jeanine this is
complete bonkers uh that we are keeping
people out
of the united states capital there's
clearly not a threat there was nothing
that happened on march 4th
the democrats are obsessed with
conspiracy theories
and they won't let them go uh we have a
border fence around
the people's house with miles of razor
wire
and speaker pelosi wants to keep it up
she doesn't want a
southern border to protect us from
illegal aliens uh you know we have
biden and his handlers who aren't just
dropping bombs on foreign countries
they're blowing up our own agencies from
within
they want to render our immigration and
customs enforcement
useless and if they pass hr1 through the
senate the democrats will have millions
of illegal voters
some of them criminals to help democrats
keep the control
in 2022. now i genuinely don't know
if anything that she said there is true
some of the stuff is like three or four
layers
removed from reality if democrats
were to try to get more undocumented
immigrants into the united states
it would have no impact on the 2022
election because undocumented immigrants
can't
even register to vote there has been
think back to the 2020 election and
all of their claims about dead people
voting people voting twice all this
stuff
they've barely even mentioned that
undocumented immigrants voted and
they've not even been able to
demonstrate that a single one did
and now she claims as if it's a foregone
conclusion
that the undocumented immigrants that
joe biden is supposedly letting into the
country
are all going to vote somehow in 2022
how do you
even register to vote if you are not a
citizen of the united states they never
have an answer
to that question and then understand
the absurdity of lauren beaubert
saying it's democrats obsessed with
conspiracy theories
bobert is the one who tries to bring
guns into the house
and claims the conspiracy is with the
metal detectors
to try to disarm her she started her
campaign
fighting against the imaginary idea that
democrats were trying to
come and confiscate her guns beaubert
has previously expressed support for q
anon
but said she wasn't a follower just that
she hopes that it's true
these people make us a laughingstock
around the world and they don't even
know it
and if you were able to convince them
they wouldn't even care her followers
see this stuff and they believe it and
they're proud
to have her representing them she says
well
listen nothing ended up happening on
march 4th that's right
q anon thought trump would be
re-inaugurated on march 4th
it was never going to happen there was
nowhere for them to go the capital was
locked down so of course nothing
happened
but that doesn't prove anything and
notice she doesn't bring up january 6th
when a very much q anon enmeshed group
of people
violently stormed the capital and
actually very briefly
delayed the counting of the electoral
vote this is a really common tactic
with conspiracy theorists you deflect
by saying why are you so obsessed with
this conspiracy which i
previously promoted you're more obsessed
with q anon than the people supposedly
following q
maybe it doesn't even exist the way
tucker carlson said a couple weeks ago
saying
i couldn't even find an official q a on
website so i don't even know that it's
real
i don't see the lauren bobert story
ending well i think the most benign
possible ending
is she just loses in 2022 and goes away
or maybe knowing she's going to lose
chooses not to run
the other endings are all worse either
she gets reelected and this type of
thing becomes a bigger piece
of our elected uh house and senate uh or
she's involved in some insane incident
the likes of which i wouldn't even
want to speculate on that but i i uh i'm
not particularly
optimistic that the lauren bobert as an
elected official story
um is going to end particularly well we
have a voicemail number
that number is 2192davidp you can call
it
anytime i you know i guess you may some
people call it 3am you don't have to but
people do uh here's an interesting
question this is a
show production question i like this
take a listen to this
hey david this is steven here long time
fan and listener member um
you have an interesting question for you
here um you've been
doing this for years now over a decade
when you film these videos are you able
to
do them all in one take or does it still
take you several times i know it
likely varies from video to video but
generally generally
for you um
are you able to do it at all in one day
thanks david appreciate all you do
and uh yeah i hope this gets played it
has
nothing to do with how long i've been
doing the show and it does not vary
video to video this show from the
beginning
has always been a one take show there's
no cuts
there's no edits it's all it's all there
and the the only exceptions where we
would do a cut
is is if there's a technical issue which
tends to happen more during interviews
than anything else there there are
sometimes situations during an interview
where we will lose
the connection with the guest on skype
and then we'll kind of like reconnect
and get situated
and then we'll cut it in some way so it
appears seamless but yes this is a
one-take
show no insult to the people that do
like the cut up thing where it's like
you film a line at a time and cut it
together with jump cuts that's a style
that's not the style we do and remember
that this started as a radio show
where you're just live so i from the
beginning was just always thinking of
this as one take so yes the entire show
is one take it always has been and i
mean i don't know
you can't predict the future 100 but i
can't think of any reason why that would
change in the future
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today
there are so many people furious with
senator kirsten cinema
for her thumbs down votes on including
the minimum wage in the covid bill
in the senate over the weekend we are
going to talk about that we are going to
talk about kirsten cinema
we are also going to talk about
something that we kind of previewed
six months ago and the explanation for
this is is maybe counterintuitive
driving was way down in 2020 because of
the pandemic a lot of people working
from home eliminating commutes
we know all the reasons why and yet
traffic fatality rates
went up why we talked about some of the
reasons six months ago now we have a
more detailed report and lastly
switzerland has voted narrowly but they
have voted
to ban face coverings in public this is
actually
a even before the pandemic and masking
we talked about switzerland and face
coverings
and it was mostly a religiously related
conversation
they have moved forward with a ban on
face coverings in public and we are
going to talk about
that on the bonus show get instant
access to the bonus show by becoming a
member at joinpacman.com or by becoming
a patron
at patreon.com david pakman show and
remember
friday march 26th we will have a
single day huge membership bomb
with a massive discount we had a
disastrous february from the standpoint
of memberships
the pandemic continuing to weigh
economically on a lot of people a lot of
people canceling
february being a short month not that
many people replacing the cancellations
it was our worst month in a long time so
we're going to try to get something
going
i would love it if you took advantage of
this one day membership
special friday march 26th if you want to
be put on the list
very exclusive list to be notified of
the special
just get on our mailing list at
davidpakman.com
and i will see you in mere moments on
the bonus show
otherwise tomorrow i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using 45 percent
less water but with a stream of water
that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman